[Music]
so i figured since we were covering this
from the beginning we could kind of do a
quick little checkup to see how the
whole breakup thing is going
you know the um
the whole uh bobby lee uh breakup thing
i think my my shorter ones do i have a
shorter one than this i think i might
no
yeah here it is okay this is shorter
that one's longer so i figured we'd
check up to see how the whole breakup
thing's going so um
andrew schultz was on um i guess it's a
podcast called bad friends is the only
comedy scene just like
six different comics just doing each
other's shows every week like that's all
it is right because every time i see
this show it's like the same people
and
it's the same people
outside of rogan to give rogan credit
well he's rogue and rogan will get like
different people from all over the world
on right but every time it's like oh
andrew schultz is going to be on bobby
lee's podcast and then bobby lee is
going to be on on br chrysler's podcast
and they're both going to be on tom
segura's podca it's like the same it's
just the same line in and out you know
same it's just like a ever-evolving jam
band but it's the same musicians yeah
yeah
this is the show he does with santino i
guess yeah
hey
how are you doing buddy
dude you look different yeah
next level you look next level i'm
italian why are you so far away from
each other
i i don't understand the setup it seems
like a lot of waste hey welcome to the
show go down next keep going it's it's
like the scene in goodfellas when he's
trying to get her to go down the alley
to get the dresses i keep going i
thought it was a scene in the simpsons
when they eat at mr burns mansion it's a
long table and they're sitting all the
way at the end that's what it feels like
right yeah the italy gets more italiano
yeah yeah first of all i know what i see
on your wrist shoulders what is that i
know what it is it's a little something
bro what is it it's a little something
bobby doesn't know about watching
business bobby what
it's more than your car
well i see diamonds on it no diamonds no
diamonds
diamonds yeah but there's like it's like
it's like uh shiny it is shiny yeah yeah
what makes it shiny the silver yeah let
me ask you a question
let me ask you a question
fast-paced comedy
shiny let me just silver
what makes it shiny let me say maybe the
fact that since you guys are only doing
each other's shows all the time
the only thing you could talk about is
how shiny his watch is because there's
not like
what are you working on it's like
nothing left you know what i'm working
on i was on your show last week bro yes
let me ask you questions about it right
i don't know much about it right neither
do i i'm a fraud how come that camera's
quality and i look we have shitty
cameras i'm not saying we don't but how
come that camera's quality is so much
worse than the other twos and are those
inflatable couches
they look inflatable everything's at
west anderson i'm telling you all these
shows are west anderson is this
different one there's just a sleepy
indian chick or some kind of sleepy
filipino chicken i think that's kala's
niece
i think
i think can they stop
i don't know man filipino people like to
have babies i can't make them stop
all right so
is it um stainless steel it's steel yeah
it's a stainless steel because that's
the good stuff right no no they lo they
want it to stain now all they do yeah
stain steel everybody likes stained
steel right does it have a does it do
does it
does do multi-purpose stuff this is
painful i'm also i'm trying to get to
them
i'm rudy
nice to meet you rudy jules yeah this is
andrew schultz wait your name is really
rudy jules no it's joe's but you made it
up but i made it up because rudy
giuliani little jewels little jewels
queen in new york [ __ ] new york and
you're not even
look tall you thought you'd be much
taller hold on you know because she is i
know i know yeah but you know what this
is this is his tactic here no i know i
was thinking maybe she shouldn't be here
but don't think dude i know but the
thing is she's here
in new york and you're not even
what what did you say because she saw
you
okay so she thought you'd he'd be short
yeah cause i saw him on tick-tock how
tall are you i i have a short uh upper
body torso how tall are you sean six too
so we're similar in height people will
say to me when they see me live oh i
thought you'd be shorter because i think
tall people don't look tall on are you
all legs or do you have torso i'm pretty
luggy yeah dad's pretty like when we sit
down we look small yeah i look at the
camera go ahead two seconds and you miss
it but it's a time warp yeah
i get reverse when people
yeah bobby we haven't spoken since here
it is since what since your whole thing
since you're free
because you know she is the niece
he doesn't give a [ __ ] so we gotta we
gotta are you a spy yeah she's around
she's a [ __ ] no i'm not
you can't get away
but what's wrong with you you keep
inviting me so what happens is he's
emotionally broken and he overreacts by
being as goofy and wacky as possible
she seems pretty sad you're behind enemy
lines i know dude get her out of here no
i know i was thinking maybe she
shouldn't be here but don't think dude i
know but thank you
15 years to get out of that relationship
i know i know yeah but you know what
this is his tactic what is it he keeps
the enemies close so so he can
lose you don't know his plan
he's gonna bang the knees yeah
if
does every girl in l.a just sit on a
chair with their feet on the chair yeah
yeah yeah
be your neighbors keep them next door
he lives downstairs they live upstairs
it's really small we live in the same
way are you guys still in that same
place in the same hill but he's still
living with her
this is weird right he's still living
with her place yeah but she's also we
sleep on the same bed
you guys broke up publicly by the way
publicly broke up publicly
like actually went on like a pretty good
little
back and forth
put all your business out there
you both talk [ __ ] about each other on
podcasts and then go home and sleep in
the same bed
but don't [ __ ]
i think they're [ __ ] i really do
think they are i think that was part of
the problem with the relationship was
they weren't [ __ ] i know and that's
my point is now they are because they're
not together oh maybe
what
this is but but it's a double it's
pushed together they just separated no
it's not no we sleep on the same bed
what i do is i have a long pillow yeah
and i just put it between us yeah
you know yeah what does that do oh a
long pillow oh my god what i thought you
were saying like an asian sound yeah
like a long fellow like did i say wong
pillow no i thought it was like long
pillows i said long pillow i was
spelling it l-u-o-n-g oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like from the
makers of long pillows
okay i'm sorry
i got something else
there's more but forget it uh this is
another clip about this is this is him
on another show
i don't know who this is someone's going
to tell me who this is i'm sure i don't
know who this is i want to know what's
next for you then you're just going to
take some time
let me ask you this forget this how do
you heal how do you move on when the
person's literally
under your roof in the bed next to you
how do you move what is that
there's no healing there's no healing no
because you said you were heartbroken
you
said those things we're both heartbroken
about it so how do you unbreak your
heart
over there
yeah but what's the what
[Music]
what soothes us is that we
have a deep
she's the love of my life i believe that
and oh my god this l.a [ __ ] needs to
stop
it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
man-babies [ __ ] acting like every
podcast is their therapist office
i mean look i've been waiting for north
korea to do something about that place
for a long time holy [ __ ] you mean the
good koreans if they just can't seem to
build a rocket that'll reach no but it's
not even just bobby bobby's just a
symptom of l.a that's why i want them to
new galileo yeah it's just
i know that doesn't mean it needs to be
intimate i know i know i love her more
than i i can't she's like
i'll tell you how i feel about her i
feel about her like i feel about my
brother
well if she feels she feels like she
feels about you the way she feels about
her brother then she'll [ __ ] you
yeah i mean she's [ __ ] her brother she
said she [ __ ] her brothers
step and reel
and you thought
that's the girl i'm gonna marry
you i mean in terms of like
like i'm gonna know this person
if she ever needed anything you know i
mean i would give her a lung
but you couldn't give her your dick was
that like an asian sound long
don't [ __ ] even joke like that
don't do that [ __ ] la comedy [ __ ]
abbott and costello [ __ ] they were doing
on bad friends
right
like that's how i feel about her you
know um
she's my best friend and um
i also
love our relationship
on our podcast and we work so well
together it's such a good ying yang
first off racist
um
secondly no i've seen your podcast it's
pretty boring it is pretty boring except
when you and your now ex-girlfriend are
fighting and revealing each other that's
really personal business throwing each
other under the bus
that's awesome
and it's interesting that
the ghost no i'm just sitting here
thinking about it now and you guys as a
couple
your child has been tiger belly you have
built that from like you said 50 [ __ ]
well your child's [ __ ] and i hate to
break it to you
in iceland your child wouldn't exist
downloads everybody starts at one
download yeah we all started at one yeah
and you've built that together and look
at it now yeah [ __ ] thriving it's
thriving yeah yeah so to to have to
pivot in your relationship from this
um romantic boyfriend girlfriend couple
and to this professional couple and
still maintain i think it's pretty
impressive i know you're you're still
newly into it but well no i mean because
if you look at i think the real i think
you look at like
does he have a dramamine patch on behind
his ear
that or a band-aid
i don't know what chris pratt and anna
faris's relationship is it but it
doesn't seem like they're divorced i
know i know they're both remarried but i
feel like i feel like it's there's some
maybe some hostility or ugliness in that
relationship right
so hear me out
you
don't like that people
are [ __ ] on your personal life
because you put it out there
but you
will [ __ ] on chris pratt's personal life
and he famously has not put it out there
but that's different oh okay
right and i don't ever want to be like
that with kalila right so i i i look at
other hollywood
or like you know other
hollywood
everybody that has one of these [ __ ]
shows and is doing the same live reads
that we are by the way you're not
special boys
um we we get the same ad packs you guys
do i'm just saying they act like oh a
little bigger we listen blue chew we
know yeah well yeah we got hymns let me
keeps we know it's the same
harry's razors
[ __ ]
whatever but
those are some premium qualities they
are premium quality rating as money no
they're not hey harry's razors listen
here
i shave my head and i want to say the
only razors i trust with my head are and
i'm going to mute this part and then
we'll just add whatever sponsor because
it might be dollar shave cup too the
only razors that i use are
there perfect there you go live read for
the future
two people because you know kalila i'm
starting uh mercies razors where you we
charge you uh ten bucks a month and we
mail you broke old broken motorola
razors
i told you ten years ago not to buy it
in the box and you bought it in bulk and
now you have to unload them i thought it
would they break
i can't do that it has to be good for
business i got to unload all 50 of them
they're stanzos they're really good
they
smell we're
you know
we we're not a regular relationship our
relationship is out in the public we're
in the public eye right
and it puts a different dynamic on the
relationship you know i mean and so it's
like because we're in the public eye
and i i don't want to get resentful i
don't want the relationship to sour it's
going to and and but if you don't want
the relationship to shower right and
you're gonna want to get resentful how
come she goes on trash tuesday and
always talks all this [ __ ] about you
because it kind of feels like maybe she
doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah i mean it kind of feels like she
never gave a [ __ ]
she never nobody ever knew who she was
until she [ __ ] bobby lee nobody knew
who i was until i put bobby lee's dick
in my mouth which i i do think if you
[ __ ] bobby lee you deserve to be famous
but you know right yeah no why do you
think will sasso had a career
i'm kidding i like will samsung have
these deep resentments and this and that
so
we're mindfully doing it in a healthy
way so that we can and if that's the
case why doesn't [ __ ] bobby lee's
cousin have a career and still have our
love
right and still have a business
and still continue in that way yeah i
mean that's right keep a brave face for
those advertisers they want to make sure
when they renew their car was august
yeah when they renew their contracts in
august you got to make sure that
everything's up and up that this show's
not going anywhere
you don't want another
fighter in the kids situation where
brian callan disappeared and then they
realized his hoes were lying and then
they had to awkwardly bring brian callan
back and none of these people ever
apologized to him no none of them nope
not even yo not even shaw b because
schaab didn't fight for him b shop kept
doing the show with black guys job
replaced him with like a young version
of dr dre and ed lover yeah
yeah
which leads me to this same vein
um
a lot of people been catching on about
brendan shaw keeps lying about how he
was poor when he was a kid when he said
many times that his fa his father was
rich
so uh here's a good example
and as far as like the the work ethic
stuff and owning your own stuff
my dad you know i'm the dumb one of the
family
you don't say
you're the dumb one and you're the dumb
one in any room you walk into
you understand that brendan
do you get that
so my my brother's a computer programmer
my dad is a computer programmer started
his own company but he was a police
remember you sell computer parts door to
door and his little briefcase
penis bro
you told me right no by a
father-in-law's police officer my
yeah so but so my father created like
basically like any of the high security
email encrypted emails that like the
government uses or like jewelry stores
like sense of material he designed all
that like
sense of material
sense of material
in early like late 80s
like early 90s somebody that's wicked
smart so growing up so i'm the dumb one
but my dad is like the ultimate
businessman the ultimate so when i was
10 i grew up in
venice in the summers because my uncle
had a house here
i was poor people do like like all of us
some of us we just summer in venice so
for me it was martha's vineyard but i
get it
look we all have different different hot
spots okay you you for you it's that
someone in the hamptons yeah yeah yeah i
go to the poconos myself damn i grew up
in that and he was a professional
bodybuilder so i grew up in that
atmosphere oh also professional
bodybuilder so he was
one and his dad was a super genius
computer guy
and his uncle was a bodybuilder
wait wait who is a professional
bodybuilder my uncle your uncle okay so
i grew up in the summers being around my
uncle who's insanely successful in a
crazy businessman and then my dad too
and i remember and a bodybuilder and a
bodybuilder okay i remember my dad i was
like 10 or 12. so i was like man i keep
slipping how gangster is this
in fourth grade i brought my oh no
i brought my so i wore my cleats to
school so if i'd walk through the
hallways and it was like clanking
everyone's making fun i'm like hi [ __ ]
wait recess wait till we get the [ __ ]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait how old are you in fourth grade
i don't know what is great you know how
old are we in fourth grade ten ten and
you wore your cleats to school and your
mom let you leave the house with cleats
on
10 11. so
so i knew i was like all right [ __ ]
keep talking [ __ ] and they're like
making fun of me because the teacher's
like you know what's funny about this
right now the fact nothing
the fact that brendan schaab is still
getting on podcasts yeah it really is
amazing to me
did you wear a sneaker ahead super now
but you were you were flexing back then
you had so yeah
and everyone's making fun of me and then
recess came and you're like just waiting
the boy went off i was like so funny now
is it so i wore those every day for the
rest of the year but what's great about
that so you went to school every day
with clayton you were annoyingly walking
down the hallways making that noise
every day oh god brenton
my mom loved it because we didn't grow
up with a lot of money and be
poor
they didn't grow up a lot of money were
poor
but you just said in venice
beaut they were poor in their home in
venice but you just said your dad and
your uncle were super mega businessman
bodybuilders bodybuilders
you just told me that your dad was a
millionaire cowboy astronaut
and now you're telling me you're poor
in the same
in the same
conversation everything he does dude
everything he does is just this lie but
most people don't lie about something
they lied about 30 seconds prior
yeah you're right you're right but not
everyone is brendan chav and has it has
a showtime [ __ ] career not earned my
god
hold on sorry
yes they wear down so by the end of the
year they wore down my mom's like see
you got shoes now my dad is like the
ultimate businessman so i grew up in the
summers being around my uncle who's
insanely successful in a crazy
businessman my mom loved it because we
didn't grow up with a lot of money
oh he put it together i see what he did
and not only that but
dude
he's so famous bro brennan is so famous
that they
randomly stop him in the streets to ask
about fights
that's how famous he is here's a totally
real interaction with him because just
like tmz they caught up with him in the
streets
fight hub tv
first off what do you make jake paul
fighting fighting i seen rachman jr
uh jake paul is not a dumb uh person
you are the and by the way you're the
expert on that the reason he's fighting
him
jake paul i think knocks him out if
you've seen the hassan rockman junior's
uh cardio it's gonna be an issue for him
especially staying under the the weight
bro he wants to be rogan so bad it it
it's never going to happen
crazy how bad he wants to be rogan limit
the you know the weight
kind of stipulation i put in the
contract so
jake should get it done listen he's not
going to mess up the bag to fight nate
diaz mike tyson and conor mcgregor he's
not going to waste on this guy so he
gets it done he's too smart does he
i don't okay he's a real boxer
but there's
this channel has
1.3 million subscribers wow
1.3 million subscribers really nation's
there so like
if he wins like do you give him a credit
like oh okay he beat a real boxer or
it's still like whoa you put these
weight who's the idiot interviewing him
he sounds like that's why i wanted to
see how many views there is god the
fight commentary people
they're they're no better than pro
wrestling
vloggers and stuff i give them more of a
break because at least they're not also
trying to be comics at least they stay
in their lane you know what i mean like
that doesn't really bug me if you stay
in your lane but
you know